the first page is one being questions so
here's what my graph looks like i will
point out you've got your hyperbola
there which i think most people are
pretty good at drawing it but x squared
equals 8 why that's y equals x squared
on 8 which is very shallow so if you
drew like a normal / avila it would have
been well just what it looked very
different and your scale would be off
same basic shape though okay so that's
what your graph should look like if I
were marking this so you got two marks
there yet where do you think you put the
two marks too much just keep in mind
what part one is and all it asks you to
do I expect there's one mark for the
hyperbole and one laughs for the
parabola right we will get to a point of
intersection in a minute but it has
nothing to do with part one and it's
marks does that make sense so if you're
marking your friends you want to make
sure you've got a I mean I've been a
little bit naughty to haven't put a
point for scale there so let's put
something like this and where's another
one I could put well if that's that then
what does that point have to be it's an
eighth right sorry that's one and anyway
okay so there you go we're looking
mainly for curvature let's have a look
at part two sure the corner to the point
of intersection of the two graphs ah oui
I've talked endlessly about the value of
saying what you're doing right so if
what you're looking at right now in
front of you is just a bunch of
equations there obviously if it's all
correct if all the equations are correct
you're not going to surrender any marks
but I would contend that you surrendered
the clarity of your proof it is a proof
isn't it like you've got a given result
you've got to get there yeah you didn't
have to redraw a diagram for this but I
think you were kind of kidding yourself
if you at least didn't go back to your
original diagram and have a see at what
you could do with the area of the region
bounded by here we go number one x axis
number two the curves plural and number
three boundaries okay so here's my
picture
over here right you can see I've got the
x axis there on the bottom and then I've
got the curves plural as well as by my
zero boundary and my to e boundaries you
see what I've done there okay now having
drawn it like this it becomes abundantly
clear that you've got two integrals here
right like you should for money useful
form the other this is not the
difference between two this is energy
roll over here the black line at the
moment up here is irrelevant right to
for me that and then over here the blue
line is irrelevant it's not going to
come in okay so once you draw this
diagram it becomes very easy to fall
there correct integrals that's what it
should look like so you've got zero to
two to do the parabola to two to e to do
the hyperbola and you can see the way my
numbers pan out a little bit of work
with your log laws and a careful
evaluation or your boundaries and I
think you should have gotten four thirds
or why did a third units square happy
you mean they've left it like what are
they left at us that's a bit sad that's
a beard set okay let's have a look at
this well okay all right you guys can
help me out there are three marks you're
the marker where do you think the three
marks should go ok so the formation of
the integrals I think that's a really
really good line let's put one there ok
now I'm going to pause you there as a
marker right I want to make things as
easy ok for myself I see this is three
marks and I see it's not a given result
it's not a given result so that means
the result you end up with will be one
of the box yeah does that make sense so
now what's left for me is well I've got
one last ma to place where do you think
would be an appropriate spot do do you
think the second line let's think about
this let's say that's because you've
noticed there are three marks but there
are more than three feet so we have to
make a decision well you ready ok so
let's actually I'm not gonna put a mark
on yet but that's actually dissect what
are the skills that have been
demonstrated ok in the first place and
this is a really really big thing right
you're forming integrals on the basis of
the area
right and that's really hard the
students will often muck that up okay so
cool I think that definitely guarantees
above then when we go forward you've got
integration here what happens in the
next loan this is the evaluation of the
boundaries right what follows after that
I think most of us agree like this stuff
in here is simplification which is
important but is not the main emphasis
of the question ok so I think you know
what whatever happens down here I'm
going to sort of let that go which to
answer the original question right 32 on
24 I think you scraped through and
you're going to get that one okay
because because what is this question
about lot about fractions it's not
really even about the log laws that you
end up needing down here I probably
would have won an extra mark on that
clearly the more important part and it's
really just an argument so I should rub
this off to is either going to be this
or this now when I look at this question
and where it fits in the context of the
rest of the paper I think if this was
actually hit exam right I think I'd lean
towards the evaluation of the boundaries
now this is a genuine 5050 the reason
why is because that first part the
integration right I'm assessing
differentiation elsewhere in this paper
in fact I'm assessing this exact result
right so if I've assessed that I'm not
going to pay someone to marks for
demonstrating the same skill twice I
know it's in Reverse but it's pretty
close where is there's nothing else like
the evaluation of boundaries anywhere
else with my paper or anywhere else in
this question etc okay but on another
day if I might have gone the other way
do you see how it's all that there are
four things here and i'm going to pick
three of them it'll be this or that
doesn't make sense okay so there's my
area oh by the way it is an area but if
you didn't have units are there I'd be
very tempted to lop off that hallmark
okay again because there's nowhere else
in this paper that units have been
assessed and it quite clearly states
you're fighting an area not evaluating
integral the integral is how you get the
area
okay whew derivatives what do you think
agree so let's just quickly start too
much through Shh you've got a standard
Proctor all and you got a standard chain
rule here and then you've got a standard
question all right so there's nothing
out of the ordinary you'll also notice I
have twice I've said look you've got
these two ways of doing it and you got
these two ways of doing it because the
question simply states differentiate
right either of those homes is fine
which four would be simplest it kind of
depends on where the question is going
you can see why I've done this right
like why would I do that where where
might this question be going come on why
do you differentiate you're either
you're either graphic or more commonly
you're finding a stationary point in
which case having this factorized makes
it clearer oh there are three stationary
points you see that okay so we can move
on from there right now we're looking at
some more recent contest so you actually
may well have done this question this
question was part of yeah this is the
first one so so really I was trying to
see were you able to recognize the form
now as I've showed before I think in
some way it is enormously helpful if you
highlight I'm doing step 1 i'm doing
step to move step 3 whether you put
numbers labels underline I kind of view
this as equivalent to in an english
essay when you underline the name of the
text that you're dealing with right does
that get you any marks no what's it
doing it's communicating to the marker
hey here are some things that you should
look for see i'm looking at chaucer i'm
looking at the tempers whatever it is
okay so there's my base case N equals 1
there's my assumption n equals K and
then you put your skate toilet you do
the real work ok so here's my proof you
can see the way that because this is
just a regular old series even if it's
not an AP or a GP you write out your
required to prove step this wanted here
you write it out with the second last
term in there because that's what we're
going to get out of the inductive
hypothesis ok if you forget to write it
that's ok you can sort of bring it into
here because it's still part of that
series right k squared is still in there
once you notice okay right there there's
the left-hand side of my inductive
hypothesis so then I make my
substitution and it is critically
critically important please note on
whoever's paper your marketing that
there is a reason stated for why the
substitution is made ok i think by
assumption is just the quickest way you
can say by the inductive hypothesis but
this worked fine ok and then from there
it's just some algebra yeah um please
note I think you'd be hard-pressed to
put any fewer lines than this remember
it's a proof it's a proof ok even this
under normal circumstances is a bit of a
ha yeah but I told you it was 2k plus 3k
plus 2 right but I think it's fair at
this point your extension once students
we expect you to be able to factorize an
onboard quadratic so I think you could
do that provided you've not been you
know clumsy here and tried to skip over
stuff don't don't do that ok question
sure ok this is worth oh it's worth
mystery marks ok well let's walk through
that's what through i would estimate
this question would be worth 3 i'd
probably put it 30 it's not for each
part because as you know the parts are
not rated evenly are the head they're
not waiting evenly at all so i would
probably put a test at assume that whole
theme that's one mark right which means
if four inch
since you do one of them but not the
other you just surrender that line it's
gone right it's like you've got it
you've got to get above the barrier to
get anything at all they're right and to
be fair the test of the assumption are
kinda true be all right so that should
be an easy mark really that means that
there are two marks somewhere nestled
into here where do you think they should
go okay so you might it seems a bit
strict but really you remember how I
said yeah you've got to have that phrase
by assumption in there right what that
really is part of is the actual use of
the assumption right so this whole lied
including the fact that you set a reason
for it that's one mark right there okay
using the assumption breier in and then
in here they're going to pick some point
where they feel like okay I think if
they've gotten to this point the rest of
it is very simple you might say I'd be
tempted to get to here I'd probably say
they're right if you if you showed me
this that line there they are the
expansion and you hadn't collected like
terms 2k squared plus k plus 6 k plus 6i
that doesn't look like k plus 2 times 2
k pi so you to me at all like that
doesn't look obvious there's no quick
way to factorize that whereas from here
to here it's kind of an irreducible step
I mean I know you can separate out you
can do pairs but that's like a tune of
skill in fact that's a stage five school
ok so I think we sort of let that one go
so long as you can get to that quadratic
your home okay